[Music]
Music is the language of the soul.
For thousands of years, humans have been creating
songs and symphonies which enthrall, inspire
and hypnotize.
Our history and our culture is closely entwined
with musical notes.
It should come as no surprise that music has
a profound effect on the human mind.
We've all felt it before; music helps us relax,
it gives us goosebumps and it encourages us
to push ourselves to the limit.
But what's the science behind all of this?
Here are seven psychological facts about music.
The Mozart Effect; the Mozart Effect is one
of the most popular scientific concepts surrounding
music.
It was developed by Dr. Gordon Shaw a few
decades ago, and the premise is simple; classical
music makes you smarter.
In his research, he claimed that listening
to classical music can raise your IQ by up
to 9 points.
The main basis for this line of thought has
to do with spatial reasoning.
This type of brain activity is used in math,
chess, engineering and science.
According to the Mozart Effect, classical
music boosts spatial reasoning considerably.
Maybe it's time to start playing some Mozart
while we study.
Music therapy helps repair brain damage.
Brain damage is one of the most discussed
topics in the world of psychology.
Some people suffering from brain damage go
through tremendous pain and discomfort, and
their life is seriously impacted.
But what if music could help?
New research shows that music can actually
repair brain damage, and it's been hypothesized
that music therapy could be responsible for
neurogenesis, which is the birth of new brain
cells.
Hearing music in your dreams is incredibly
rare.
Think about every dream you've ever had, can
you remember hearing music in a single dream?
If you're like the vast majority of the population,
you've probably never heard so much as a jingle
in your dreams.
According to a 2018 study, only 6% of all
remembered dreams include music.
Unsurprisingly, you're much more likely to
hear music in your dreams if you're a musician
or someone who listens to a lot of music.
But even then, the number is still very low.
Your entire brain is activated when you listen
to music.
There aren't many activities that make your
whole brain light up, but listening to music
is definitely one of them.
When you listen to music, there's not a single
part of your brain that isn't activated.
Parts of the brain that are responsible for
emotions, creativity and even motor functions
are working while listening to music.
So if you're looking for a full brain workout,
simply put on your favorite song.
Music can improve language proficiency.
The relationship between language and music
is one of the most fascinating things in the
world of psychology.
To put it simply, these two things are very
closely linked to one another.
A 2012 study pointed out that despite what
previous research suggested, music and language
are not separate functions in the brain.
Traditionally, speech functions were thought
to exist in the left hemisphere of the brain
while music functions existed in the right
hemisphere.
But today, it's widely accepted that both
hemispheres are responsible for music and
speech.
What this means is that music functions can
actually improve speech functions and vice
versa.
In a sense, both activities are working the
same muscle.
Your taste in music says a lot about your
personality.
Have you ever wondered why you like certain
music?
Have you ever wondered why your favorite songs
might sound absolutely terrible to others?
The answer lies in our unique personalities.
Numerous studies have shown that if you like
a certain musical genre, you're probably going
to have certain personality traits.
For example, a 2004 study found that extroverts
were more likely interested in music in a
general sense, but they were also more likely
to enjoy pop music.
That's just one example and there's tons of
research on this one topic.
Think about your favorite song, what does
it say about your personality?
Music therapy helps children with autism.
Remember what we said about music lighting
up the entire brain?
Well, this makes music therapy an ideal choice
for children with autism.
When both hemispheres are activated, children
are self-aware while still forming relationships
with others.
Research has shown that this type of therapy
is incredibly beneficial for autistic children
as it encourages them to interact with their
instruments and communicate with others in
a band, ultimately creating music in a collaborative
effort.
What do you think your favorite songs says about
you?
Comment below.
Thanks for watching!
[Music]